We Begin this half hour with the occasion
that brought Britain's Prince William and
Princess Kate to Boston the awarding of
the earthshot prizes dubbed the Oscars
of the earth they recognize and reward
Innovative projects addressing climate
change and other serious environmental
problems this morning Ramy Inocencio shows
us one of the winners and the work that
could solve a truly ocean-sized problem
I can announce that the 2022 Earth shot
for build a waste free world goes to notpla
and it was completely surreal Pierre Paslier
is co-founder of london-based notpla a little
wordplay of "not plastic" his startup of
determined designers chemists and Engineers
won Prince William's Earth shot award for
environmental Innovation and more than
one million dollars their mission to replace
single-use plastic with single-use seaweed for
the planet and its people a revolution we have to
look at it as a war effort because the the scale
of like the challenge is something that threatens
the whole world all at once it's in the air it's
in water it's in our blood we produce 400 million
tons of plastic waste every year says the United
Nations half of that's used just once then thrown
away much of it to live hundreds of years after
we are gone but it's very slowly fragmenting and
releasing all of these other chemicals that are
present in the plastic and the the half-life of
plastic being hundreds of years we're not going
to see the peak of that for a very long time right
we're basically poisoning ourselves in our future
Generations a poison like no other the antidote
is in nature seaweed is one of the planet's
most renewable resources it grows fast some up
to three feet in a day and it's resilient 12
000 species are found in every ocean in the
world notpla has experimented with about 30
of them concocting secret seaweed sauces and
turning them into transparent films it's like
plastic wrap but seaweed wrap how strong
it will break but it's definitely resistant
enough for a lot of applications where there's
going to be relatively quick consumption like
the Ooho little Jiggly pods for liquid on
the go they've been trialed with success
at marathons and concerts where piles of
plastic bottles are the unfortunate Norm
today's flavor is lemon mint water Cheers
Cheers here we go put it in your cheek
it's going to explode yeah all right and then
you can eat the whole thing a little nervous
there's that pop that is a pop not plot is
making more form factors for condiments too
like ketchup mayonnaise and olive oil if its
packaging ends up in landfill nature makes
quick work of it in four to six weeks for
now Paslier says Notpla's products aren't
price competitive with plastic but commercial
Partnerships are key the companies teamed up
with a UK food delivery app for seaweed line
boxes replacing plastic lining tie-ups with
bigger Brands he hopes are a matter of time
bringing the best solutions to the brands
like McDonald's and KFC and Burger King not
plus simple guiding principle to repair our
damaged Planet nature knows best for CBS
Saturday morning ramy inocencio in London
really interesting and once you get
the price down that's the big thing
right yeah I like that tagline though
nature knows best nature absolutely
very Innovative and especially after
marathon races you always see so many
things littered around it's nice to know there
is a possible solution right maybe let's see